president Donald Trump has made his
first of potentially several nominations
to the Supreme Court this time going
with an anti-science ideologue named
Neil Gorsuch a federal judge from the US
Court of Appeals for the Tenth Circuit
this is the seat that Republicans may
well end up stealing from former
President Barack Obama will be an
absolute deciding factor from a
mathematical point of view as the ninth
on a Supreme Court that has been with
only eight justices for nearly a year in
total reality show fashion it happened
at the White House let's take a look and
listen to this entire thing today I am
keeping another promise to the American
people by nominating judge Neil Gorsuch
of the United States Supreme Court to be
of the United States Supreme Court and I
would like to ask Judge Gorsuch and his
wonderful wife Louise to please step
forward please Louise judge here they
come here they come Wow awkward
yeah so Trump a little confused they're
bringing on Neil Gorsuch of the Supreme
Court to beyond the Supreme Court not
clear Trump knew what the hell was going
on but in any case it happened
Neil Gorsuch is the son of Ronald
Reagan's Environmental Protection Agency
head and Gorsuch Burford he regularly
speaks at Federalist Society conferences
who helped Trump build his Supreme Court
pick lists potential conflict of
interest there this reminds me of when
Dick Cheney was brought on by george w
bush to help him find a vice president
ended up picking himself and again the
guy who was involved with the
organization that helped trump make the
list is the guy that trump ultimately
picked here very very right-wing this
guy is a proponent for literal and these
are words which might sound sort of
innocuous but they really are code for
an extremely ideological right winger an
originalist a textualist in terms of his
interpretations of the constitution very
similar ideologically to Antonin Scalia
would not change the balance of the
court in that sense with regards to when
the court had nine individuals with
Antonin Scalia and SCOTUSblog
references or describes gore such as an
ardent defender of religious liberties
and pluralistic accommodations for
religious adherents as well as a quote
natural successor to Antonin Scalia I
don't know about you pat but anybody
that would naturally be able to succeed
Antonin Scalia is someone I'm very
scared of and they're all strict
constitutionalists in all four states
rights except when it comes to choosing
the president the United States yes in
2000 Bush v Gore says he wept when he
found out that Antonin Scalia had passed
away voted for the Hobby Lobby ruling
that gave companies the right to deny
women contraceptives said that Obama
care under rights payments for drugs or
devices that can have the effect of
destroying a fertilized human egg which
is of course medically inaccurate right
I mean it's just not accurate that
that's what contraceptives or IUDs or
morning-after pills do
this is total non-science BS strongly
against assisted suicide which is legal
in five states in euthanasia he's
written a book about these things we
have a cover of the book here the future
of assisted suicide and euthanasia no
judicial record on abortion but if he
had to guess Pat what would you think
this guy's views on abortion are I would
say he would call himself pro-life yes
he that's how he would describe himself
strongly endorsed by the powerful
Americans United for life law firm firm
he is a according to narrow pro-choice
America's President Gore such represents
an existential threat to legal abortion
in the United States no judicial record
on marriage equality but he said it
should be settled through legislatures
and elections not courts which of course
tells us he is at odds with the Supreme
Court ruling from a year plus ago which
said state bans on same-sex marriage are
not allowable and he also voted for
ruling against transgender a transgender
woman who was being denied consistent
access to hormone therapy while
incarcerated this is bad this is really
really bad and we actually have a quote
here about his view on sort of brought
more broadly issues of the power of
different branches of government
American liberals have become addicted
to the courtroom as the primary means of
affecting their social agenda on
everything from gay marriage to assisted
suicide what's so ironic is that based
on that comment there are right-wingers
who would say this guy is clearly
against using the courts for activism
but you can tell from his quote Pat that
this is his judicial activism he is a
judicial activist in this way this is
kind of the milquetoast running the mill
Republican choice but the bigger angle
here is one of the Democrats going to do
in response because they're kind of in
between a rock and a hard place well I
think that number one we shouldn't even
be here right President Obama had nearly
a year left on his second term when
Antonin Scalia passed away Republicans
said well we're too close to the next
election so we're going to wait so that
the
American people can choose the president
who will decide on who will replace
Antonin Scalia Americans had chosen the
president that would decide on Supreme
Court picks up to January 20th of 2017
it was completely arbitrary capricious
and a complete political sideshow for
Republicans to not allow President Obama
to have his say there Chuck Schumer has
said Democrats are going to demand 60
votes which hints that there may be a
filibuster coming here 60 votes are
needed to break a filibuster
I am completely onboard with Democrats
doing everything they can to fight this
to the end block it wait for a year say
hey you know what after all
Donald Trump only has three years 11
months and roughly 15 days until he
would be replaced by the next president
why don't we wait so we can let the
American people have a say and what I'm
getting at is that there's no magic
about 11 and a half months right that
pretty we were only 11 and a half months
away from the next president being
inaugurated so Obama doesn't get to pick
well then Trump doesn't get to pick
either by the same hairbrained logic I
mean I think they're kind of screwed
either way because either you allow this
to happen you allow this judge to go
through and then you're kind of
considered a pushover liberal in the
Senate or you obstruct and then this
long history of bipartisanship when it
comes to putting people on the court is
just completely gone with it was gone
when Republicans said that Merrick
garland isn't getting through and I
completely think that although you're
right that in a way it may be between a
rock and a hard place do not allow this
guy on do it just just just use the
exact same roadblocks that Republicans
used